Hey Leute, ich bin ja ein riesen Fan von neuen Technologien,
die noch nicht wirklich in unserem Alltag sind,
aber bald unser Leben verändern werden
Ob selbstfahrende Autos,
virtual reality
Oder das Internet der Dinge
Ich finds immer super spannend
und hab' höchstwarscheinlich schon ein Video dazu gemacht
Aber trage ich mit solchen Videos auch dazu bei,
dass Leute am Ende nur von diesen Erfindungen ettäuscht werden?
Es gibt ein paar Stationen
durch die anscheinend fast jede neue Technologie durch muss,
bis sie wirklich im Alltag von uns Menschen angekommen ist
Das ist der ,,Hype-Zyklus''
1995 von Jackie Fenn erfunden und bis heute
in der Technik-Branche ständig benutzt und zitiert
Hier auf der Y-Achse befindet sich die Aufmerksamkeit oder
die Erwartung an eine neue Technologie
Je höher die Kurve, desto größer der Hype
Und auf der X-Achse ist die Zeit eingetragen
das sind meistens mehrere Jahre,
hängt aber total von der Technologie ab
Am Anfang von diesem Zyklus gibt es immer einen Auslöser
ein wissenschaflticher Durchbruch,
eine Idee oder neue Forschungsergebnise
Dieser Auslöser stößt auf großes Interesse
und explosionsartig steigt der Hype an
jeder ist aus dem Häuschen
Diese neue Technik wird unser Leben verändern
Die Medien berichten viel und ausgebig
und die Erwartungen an das neue Produkt steigen ins unermessliche
Jeder will es haben
Was sich aber kaum vermeiden lässt, ist was jetzt kommt
Ein genau so schneller Abschwung in die Enttäuschung
Die ersten Prototypen der neuen Technik kommen viel zu spät an
und sind noch lange nicht Marktreif
Sie haben Kinderkrankheiten, sind überteuert und halten generell nicht das,
was man sich von der neuen Technik vorgestellt hatte
Als Folge dessen will die Presse nicht mehr darüber berichten
und die neue Technologie, die eigentlich alles verändern sollte
gerät erst einmal in Vergessenheit
Bis sie schließlich durch weitere Forschungen der Entwicklung
lange Zeit später auf einen angemessenen Stand kommt
Neue Einschätzungen der Technik durch die Medien sind jetzt viel realistischer
Die Leute verstehen die Vor- und Nachteile der Technik
und wissen, was sie kann und vor allem, was sie nicht kann
Und so ganz langsam kommt man dann gegen Ende der Entwicklung
mit der zweiten oder dritten Generation des Produkts auf eine stabile Ebene
Das Produkt verändert am Ende vielleicht doch unser Leben drastisch,
aber nicht ganz so, wie wir uns das zunächst vorgestellt hatten
Oder es stellt sich heraus, dass es doch eher ein Nischenprodukt ist
und wir im Alltag kaum etwas damit zu tun haben
Das ist der ,,Hype-Zyklus'' kurz zusammengefasst
Natürlich ist das alles nicht wissenschaftlich
Es gibt zum Beispiel keine Möglichkeit ,,Hype'' wirklich zu messen
Deswegen gibt es immer wieder Technologien, die aus dem Muster herausfallen
Und die Namen für die einzelnen Stationen sind auch irgendwie theatralisch
Trotzdem gibt die Firma Gartner einen neuen Hype-Zyklus-Chart heraus
Der heilige Gral in der Technik-Branche
Hier lässt sich alles schnell ablesen
Welche Technologien sind gerade im Trend und super spannend?
Zum Beispiel selbstfahrende Autos
Welche arbeiten sich gerade durch die steinige Entwicklung und kommen erst in ein paar Jahren wieder?
zum Beispiel 3D-Drucker für Konsumenten
Und am wichtigsten: Was steht uns in wenigen Jahren bevor?
Welche Erfinfungen kennt heute noch keiner, die bald der große Hype sein werden
Bio-acoustic Sensing: Unsere Haut als ,,Touchscreen'' oder smart dust
Schwärme von micro-Robotern und Sensoren, die durch Computer-Netzwerke kontrolliert werden
Das klingt nach vielen, vielen Videos, die ich zu diesen ganzen Themen machen kann
wobei ich dann automatisch zum Hype und damit unausweichlich zu der Enttäuschung beitragen werde, die danach kommt
Es ist irgendwie ein bisschen schade, dass man nicht von Anfang an realistisch an neue Erfindungen herangehen kann
dass sie anscheinend immer wieder zunächst überbewertet werden
Aber ich finde den Hype-Zyklus auch super um Technologien, die ich schon lange verfolge,
besser einschätzen zu können
Zum Beispiel virtual reality
Dieses Jahr sind endlich die Ersten consumer-Varianten der VR-Headsets rausgekommen
und obwohl sie noch teuer, umständlich und definitiv nicht perfekt sind,
spürt man der Technik so langsam an, was wirklich dahinter steckt
Autonome Autos befinden sich laut Gartner gerade an der Spitze des Hypes
Und das glaube ich gerne, denn meine eigenen Erwartungen an die Technik sind gerade enorm
Revolution der Logistik-Branche, drastischer Rückfall von Verkehrsumfällen und entspanntes Auto fahren, bei dem man Filme gucken kann
Noch gibt es aber nur Prototypen und dass das alles nicht so schnell geht und nicht genau so, wie wir uns das vorstellen
könnte uns bald stark enttäuschen
Bis die Technik dann nach einiger Forschung und harter Arbeit vollkommen im Alltag angekommen ist und von uns angenommen wurde,
wird wohl noch viel zeit ins Land gehen
Genau so wie das Internet der Dinge oder wearables
Wir haben gesehen, dass das alles funktioniert
aber momentan wollen die wenigsten Leute einen tweetenden Toaster oder Videobrillen beim spazieren gehen
Wir müssen herausfinden, wie man diese Dinge wirklich sinnvoll ins unseren Alltag integrieren kann
Wenn ihr euch für sowas interesssiert, würde ich euch empfehlen einfach mal mit den Cycles der letzten Jahre rumzuspielen
und zu sehen, wie sich die verschiedenen Erfindungen entwickelt haben
Alle Links zum Thema findet ihr wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung direkt unterm Like button
Viel Spaß dabei, ich bin raus, haut rein, euer Cedric